Yop you know Oprah would be a lot of fun
I know her very well you know I did one
of her last show she had Donald Trump's
before politics her last week and she
had Donald Trump and my family is very
nice no I like Oprah I don't think she's
the president earlier today responding
to a report over Winfrey might be the
savior for the Democrats against him in
2020 something the liberal media has
been completely giddy about here with
the reaction the hills Joe Koch and
president Trump's daughter-in-law and
senior advisor for Trump 2020 Laura
Trump is with us first of all
congratulations I just saw pictures of
the baby
thank you absolutely that hair is to die
for
it's amazing look I don't I honestly
think that when all the noises settles
at the end of the day the fact that we
have two million fewer people on food
stamps the economy is turning around
every indicator I won't go through the
list
oh my gosh we could go on for four hours
right hey I have a hundred and some
accomplishments in year one yeah well
listen let's not forget that is what the
strategy is for 2020 that is what my
father-in-law is going to run on the
incredible achievements we've already
seen he hasn't even been in office for a
full year and look at what he's done so
I would love to know if Oprah is who we
have to run against in 2020 she's an
incredible woman I think she has many
many accomplishments and are about a
great television host but let's not
forget Donald Trump in 2016
defeated 16 incredible GOP candidates
and Hillary Clinton said he had no shot
and it's gonna be a lot harder I think
to run against him in 2020 than anybody
is suggesting right now and I think
Oprah would be very smart to sit this
one out
yeah why is there a desire always of the
media Joe for their savior because we
know that they wake up in the morning
seeing what what they can hate Donald
Trump about for any given day Sean I
think the media is advocating for an
Oprah Winfrey candidacy because never in
the history of clicks and ratings would
there be
anything better from an infotainment
perspective from a business perspective
than winfrey versus trump in 2020 and I
just find it amazing that the same media
that derided a political novice and a TV
host for having the audacity to run in
2016 is now he's ruling over the
prospect of Oprah Winfrey to it yeah in
2020 yeah you know what are the things I
always like to ask you because I I watch
the attacks on your family you know that
they are they always wanted to get
Donald Trump they never thought he'd win
then he wins then they were attacking
her that doesn't Russia collusion not
proven a lot is now boomeranging back
but it's hard as how hard has it been on
your family um listen it's it's I won't
lie and say it's been easy it's hard
every single day we get hit from every
possible angle no matter what we do
we're gonna get hit so I think for all
of us it's about making sure that we
support my father-in-law and the
incredible job that he's doing for this
country and is good for the country
it is there's no two ways about it in
come February first when people have a
lot fatter paycheck even the people that
didn't vote for Donald Trump are gonna
say wait a minute maybe this guy is on
to something maybe this tax reform was a
good thing how is the babies four months
old right almost four months old this
week has he been in the Oval Office
Jimmy has actually Eric tweeted a
picture out of him there oh he has the
same desk that John F Kennedy had and
Ronald Reagan had and they have they
still have that opening I think he may
be the youngest to sit behind that desk
oh is that true yeah I would take the
picture in the opening - yeah and
definitely with the hairstyle I saw
today is amazing all right last word Joe
concha it really I think at the end of
the day the noise goes away
is the economy better and do we are we
safer as a country and how many promises
did he keep well that's what you have to
look at Shawn was what was the five
biggest issues that voters voted on in
2016 according to most polls economy
okay what you could say things are going
excellent as you pointed out before jobs
unemployment at a 17-year low Isis the
caliphate 98% of it destroyed healthcare
incomplete that didn't work out in 2017
and then obviously immigration which is
being discussed today or in year two now
so
so if four of those five are kept I
don't see Wisconsin Pennsylvania Ohio
Michigan those states where trade and
economy were really important it's hard
to see those boats again it depends on
the Democrats that was two hundred three
hundred miles of the wall great to see
you welcome back
yeah I'm grats on the baby thank you